Speaker 1: Let's see who else we have
holding on today. Oh, let's go to Taylor from
Indiana. Taylor, you've called in before, right?
Speaker 3: I don't believe that I have. No. Okay.
Speaker 1: Well, welcome anyway.
Speaker 3: Thank you.
Speaker 1: What's on your.
Speaker 3: Mind? I wanted to do well. I wanted to
read a quote from John Adams and then discuss it.
Speaker 1: Okay. I'm a little
has it. Do you have a question?
Speaker 3: I do. Okay. All right. To the quote.
Okay. He said this pertaining to the forming
of the country, the American Revolution and the
Constitution. Okay. He said, quote, It will never
be pretended that any persons employed in that
service at interviews with the gods or were
in any degree under the inspiration of heaven
more than those that work upon ships or houses
or laboring in merchandise or agriculture. Okay.
It will forever be acknowledged that
these governments were contrived merely
by the use of reason and the senses. End
quote. I'm one. I guess my question is,
how did we get to this point that it seems
like. Right. Like somebody cannot be even
elected to office without invoking some
type of religion. I know. And what do
we do about it? If there's anything we can.
Speaker 1: What we do about it is we need a less
Christian nationalist Supreme Court so that the
decisions increasingly separate church and state
rather than blend them together. But the big
picture I mean, the point you're getting to is
you have all these right wing Christian
dominionism, nationalist types
who want to ignore everything the Founding Fathers
said and instead go, Hey, they were personally
religious, therefore they probably didn't
want separation of church and state ignoring
everything they said, which is absolutely nuts.
Speaker 3: Right. And that's it's for the most
part, a myth that they were that the majority
of the founders were very religious. Yeah.
Speaker 1: I mean, tell me what you know about
that. I know that many of them were religious,
but not all.
Speaker 3:
Well, so one example I know of Thomas Jefferson
is famous for editing the Bible with a razorblade,
cutting out all the supernatural parts. I'm
not here to, like, promote a book necessarily,
but there's a good book by Andrew Sidel,
constitutional attorney. Yep. We've interviewed
him that I've been listening to that book.
And there's all kinds of good information in
there. The book's called The Founding Myth
Why Christian Nationalism is un-American.
Indeed. And there's just there's so many lies
from, like, all of the. All of the supposed super
Christian things that George Washington did, like
praying in the snow at Valley Forge and things
like that. It's all just completely made up. Hmm.
Speaker 1: Well, I don't know enough about that
to say for sure. I'll research it. But
your main point is absolutely well-taken,
and I appreciate you making it.
Speaker 3: Thank you very much.
Speaker 1: All right, Taylor, very
nice phone call. Appreciate it.